uh yes so um this is called rtdb Data
persistence with consistency and
performance in a truly serverless system
um my name is William D Tre I'm the
Arctic I'm the architect of a project
called Arctic DB um I've been software
developer for more than 20 years and for
quite a lot of that time a member of the
C++ standardization committee um I
didn't start in finance but I I moved
into the world of Finance um doing
exchange data publication at the New
York Stock Exchange and the UR next
exchanges sort of pushing data out of
those exchanges and since then I've
worked with really really large data
sets all across the finance industry uh
things like Risk modeling and data
engineering on the buy side and the sell
side which for those of you who don't
know kind of Finance jargon basically
means hedge funds and investment Banks
um I think that Arctic DB is quite sort
of uh unique in terms of the way that we
work with the with the data storage
architecture um and sort of to to
highlight that I just want to give you a
very brief tour of sort of you know how
things have happened with data storage
over over the last kind of 20 or 30
years um so the original uh day storage
architectures were called shared
everything and that meant you basically
had a node it had a dis it had some
memory it had some compute um clients
connected to it via the network and it
serve their queries and a lot of the
really big established relational
databases like post GES and MySQL and
things like that they were these kinds
of
systems slightly more recently things
have moved on to what's called a shared
nothing architecture that's where you
have a bunch of nodes and they all have
their own dis their own their own Ram
their own compute um and they can't see
any of the others storage at all uh they
just talk to each other over the
internet and at the same time they
service clients over over the network at
the same time um so there's a lot of
like very very performance systems doing
this uh sort of replicating data between
them uh for time you have things like
kind of quazar um and there you know SB
and things like that they're all very
much shared nothing
architectures and even more recently
we've started to move and see more of
the what people call shared storage
architecture and that's where the
computer and the ram is is kind of local
to where it's happening um and then that
talks to the network and behind that
Network you have a whole array of discs
um you know this can be anything from
you know hugely performant flash storage
uh cloud storage like S3 and Azure or
even just some minio cluster that you
built out of things that you found in
the skip uh but what the what the
clients do um with their computer and
their Ram is they just treat this thing
as if it's one giant kind of logically
addressable dis that they're working
with there obviously some advantages to
this mainly uh other databases have to
spend a lot of time thinking about
availability thinking about Hardware
failure dis failure you know node
failure passing replicas between each
other notifying each other something's
changed um you can just defer all that
onto the storage you know you can you
can rely on the underlying architecture
to pass all the data around and make
sure that you've got multiple copies so
if a disc catches fire you don't lose
all your data just vast capacity in them
um and also uh you know because of the
economies of scale you get with these
sorts of things you can really kind of
drive down the cost and you can choose a
cost model that you want so if you want
lots and lots of storage and you hardly
access it you can get super super cheap
but with high EG costs or you can you
sort of pay more for massive amounts of
bandwidth
um there are some drawbacks one of which
is the consistency models whilst they
been getting better of these things um
are still you know mostly eventual
consistency and if you're trying to
address as many different kind of
storages as you possibly can then you
end up with the intersection of all of
the consistency models the thing you can
rely on from every single storage and
that is actually not very much the other
thing that you get with all of these
different stores is that the performance
can be quite variable you you can pretty
much rely on read being good um write
being good Delete being good as soon as
you start kind of listing things that
require kind of indexing then your
mileage is going to seriously
vary So based on that looking at data
frame storage uh there are kind of three
things that are going on at the moment
you've got what's called olap servers
which stands for online analytical
processing usually the kind of shared
everything or shared nothing model um uh
can you know very very performance and
very high performance entrance in this
kind of C this category um they can be a
little difficult to set up and you know
you've got a server running so you need
to monitor its Health you need to have
something to restart it or you need to
pay someone to do that for you um so
they can be a little fiddly to run at
the other end of the spectrum we've got
kind of you know open colum file formats
so that's all of things like paret and
orc and things like that um super low
barrier to entry you know just right
parquet re paret um you know very very
easy to kind of get started with um if
you have a couple of hundred of them you
don't really have a big problem if you
have for example about 20,000 libraries
some of which have millions of symbols
some of which have tens of thousands of
versions then you start to have a very
very large problem with some of these um
and also you know the the model for kind
of adding data updating data is you read
the whole thing out you do some
operations on it you write it back in um
and you hope that no one else has done
the same thing at the same time time you
know so that you're overwriting their
changes or you know they're overwriting
your
changes this has led to the growth of uh
what are called hybrid stores and the
idea with that is that you store the
really big stuff in one of these open
file formats often or an extended
version of one of them and then you use
some kind of uh assd compliance server
just to store the top level which is
usually called a catalog um so you get
some of the benefits of having an open
file format you know you just write lots
and lots of stuff directly to your
storage but then you get
transactionality on top of that uh which
is kind of
cool the problem with that is you are
still fundamentally setting up and
running a server so you've lost a little
bit of that ease of use um you know You'
created that point of failure you kind
of brought it back in when it had gone
away um and from a design point of view
once you have the catalog there's a
temptation to kind of put more and more
stuff in it until you really just have a
kind of you know an oap server anyway
but with some stuff stored in
S3 um so what we wanted to do was to see
how far we can push the consistency
without a catalog and to know that you
kind of have to know well what does the
catalog do and I think for that you
probably need to have a little bit of
background in like you know what is
column of storage um you know what are
we kind of talking about here um and the
answer is basically you know all of
these things are fundamentally quite the
same ours pares um Orcs you name it um
you know it's it's a some kind of
descriptor that's easy to access from
lots of different languages and and
platforms could be Proto buff uh a
little bit of logical metadata about the
the actual user data you're storing some
physical metadata about you know offsets
and where things are how many bites do
you need to skip if you're not
interested in that sort of thing the
data itself and then usually some other
bits and pieces around kind of you know
check sums and whatever I mean
interestingly this is very very similar
to what database files look like on disk
um there's only really a couple of
differences uh one of which is they
probably don't store everything in in
one time Block they'll they'll
amalgamate it into huge files keep track
of offsets within all of those um and
then you know maybe they'll have some
storage where that's quite fragmented
where the new stuff goes and then you'll
have you know gradually coales stuff
into larger blocks and and move it into
the older
storage so the point of the catalog in
the hybrid data store is basically just
to solve this kind of data race thing
the problem that you have is you want to
modify a block someone else wants to
modify a block of the same logical
entity and the danger is that you then
get this Franken data situation where
you see part of that change part of this
change and the whole thing is not a
logically consistent entity at all um
this is bad in lots of you know
businesses uh if you're trading billions
of dollars based on that data then you
know it's particularly bad and you
really really need to do that um you
know so they're basically allowing you
to do that block modification so simply
you just need to basically stop
modifying the blocks um unfortunately
it's really really hard to stop the
users modifying any of their data they
they don't really want to do that um so
what you can do is you can try and
create a store where the logical data
changes but the physical blocks
basically stay the same and that's
called an immutable store I think one of
the most Innovative uh original
immutable stores was called datomic and
it was done by Richard hickey who wrote
clure um there's a really nice document
store called rethink which is similar to
um but you know the good thing is
if you never modify a block then you
can't corrupt your data because when you
when you modify stuff that's when you
can corrupt it um and also you've got
all that stuff from before so so you can
travel back and you can see things as
they were either because you've reached
a really good point in research and you
want to sort of freeze things at that
point or because you know you maybe made
like a trading decision and you want to
know what was the state of knowledge at
that
time um so what do we actually want to
build with arctic DB fundamentally we
just wanted a really really simple clean
interface for storing persisting data
for doing data science for doing Quant
research in Python uh we wanted to
decouple from any particular storage so
that you know even within a single
organization you can use cloud storage
you can use you know really really
expensive super high band with super low
latency flash storage you know and you
can also use use cheaper storages for
for sort of research projects want to
make um a efficient use of that storage
space and with all of that we wanted to
make some something that
performance-wise you know competed with
the really really fast olap storage is
out there but still just a python module
and somewhere to put the data no servers
nothing to maintain you know nothing to
worry about failing and
restarting um and so fundamentally this
is it you can create an Arctic object um
you can create a little Library this
one's called Pi data Global um and I can
uh make a make a little data frame a
little simple High one and write it to
the storage and it just looks like that
um give it a symbol in a data frame read
obviously if you want to read this live.
read uh and that's my data it's a Time
series you know with with some numbers
it doesn't have to be a Time
series there are two kind of challenges
with immutable data in storage one of
which is if you think you're doing
immutable data you need to be really
really sure that you don't overwrite
those blocks because then you're going
to have like the world's worst
corruption problem um and the second one
is if you're keeping every version of
everything forever then uh you really do
need to be very careful about how you
use the storage or you're just going to
end up you know filling the disc and and
you know costing people lots and lots of
money the way that we solved the first
problem was something called Str
structured keys and it's a kind of
similar approach if you've ever se you
know worked with something like a uu ID
if you just want a universally unique
identifier what you do is you take lots
and lots of different fields all of
which refer to something about when or
where something was created what
contains and you end up with this unique
identifier one of the things about
arctic DB is it's really really open to
python not only can you read and write
your data to Python and you you know
kind of divide it into chunks you can go
in you can dig around and you can see
how we've stored it so if I read the
index of the thing that I just wrote
with the half a million rows we can see
all these Keys stored here with a little
bit of information about how it was all
sliced up on the right hand side and
that itself is also just a data frame um
and as you would expect if we look at
the the key type um this you know the
the type of this data because the the
keys are kind of semantically separated
by what they mean um is table data that
means user data that's something that
someone actually put into the into the
data
store so if I want to kind of add
something on the end of this but I don't
want to copy the whole thing again I
need some kind of persistent structure
that will let me do that um of the ones
that we use most is is persistent B
trees and so if you imagine the thing I
just wrote is all of these blue boxes
and the thing I want to add is the red
boxes um I can basically kind of append
some stuff and then from the index here
you can see that all of the stuff up to
the half million lines is version ID Zer
as in the the stuff I first wrote and
then all of the stuff I've just added on
another half a million lines is version
one and you can see how this information
helps us kind of lay it out like I said
the first version is still there we've
got we've got you know as of version
zero has got half a million lines now
we've got a million
lines sometimes for reasons I don't
understand people like to read stuff out
and just write it back exactly the same
as it was before um and one of the
really nice things about doing this is
if you do do that what happens is we do
have three versions but because we've
detected that it's exactly the same data
as it was before no new actual data has
being entered into the store the same
would be true if you kind of appended
some data but you did that by reading
everything out appending a bit you know
in pandas or whatever and writing it
back we would detect that most of this
data is actually the same and just add
on the Delta of the stuff that you
actually
want so got the data at the bottom the
index is above it we then need to kind
of track the versions as they um evolve
over time and the way we do that is by
having extra keys and these are the
version keys and so you can look inside
one of those
um just as a data frame as usual and
what you can see is that it has two
things in it it has uh if I print out
the types of these Keys it has um it has
the index of the most recent thing and
it also has a pointer to the version key
of the of the previous version so in
this case we're creating kind of like a
linked list inside the storage where
each of those previous Keys points to
the one before and then when you get to
the point where there's no new key you
know no further Keys you know you're at
the of the list um it also means that
even these don't ever have to be have to
be modified at all um because you just
read the most recent thing then you make
your new thing that points to that um
and so on and so on you're not kind of
going in and modifying some version
structure and sort of hoping that no one
else is doing that at the same time has
a fancy name it's called event streaming
just means that everything that happens
every update every deletion everything
it's all just you know an event that
happens one after another and we can
always retrace everything that happened
and by default we keep a record of all
the versions that ever existed even if
the data is gone because it got deleted
just because the metadata overhead of
that is really really
tiny um there is a bit of a snag which
is if you have these really long unique
keys where you actually start what do
you read first because the reader is not
necessarily going to know the content
hash and the Tim stamp and all of that
stuff that the writer wrote and sort of
compounding this problem is that you
know listing oper
is quite variable across the different
object stores sometimes you can read a
thousand things at a time or less and
then you you have to get a continuation
token you have to make another request
you know and then with if there's some
performance variability there as well it
can all get really slow so doing that
thousands of times making doing all
these round trips to the storage just to
read something is is going to get a
little bit sad so what we do to solve
that is we create a tiny little mutable
entry just as a kind of reference point
as a as a speed up um to basically let
us uh you know have an entry point to
that so you can see that for this
Library I've got my entry point and we
can look inside that it has two keys the
second of them actually points to the
head of that version list we were
looking at before and then we cheated a
tiny bit because uh the first one is
actually the index key of the most
recent thing so for that super common
case where you just actually want the
most recent version of the data you
don't have to do any iOS to go and
Traverse that version list at all if you
if we know it's a latest one you just
grab this and uh you know and you can go
straight read your index you know start
doing some data
processing so you might be thinking this
is all very well but you're spraying a
lot of objects around in my Object Store
and is this not going to you know become
kind of pro problematic over time and
indeed you know if I write another 10
versions now I've got 12 of these things
um but what we have is we have a whole
bunch of uh operations that for all of
this kind of background meth data
they'll just go and clear everything up
um they'll scoop it up into larger
physical blocks but you know the same
logical
content and so if I do this you can see
interestingly that it's not compacted
the very head of the the que because
that would give us consistency problems
in this kind of inconsistent you know
storage only environment but the second
one all of those uh Keys have been kind
of swept up into one
thing um so what's it for like why why
what do we kind of use these techniques
for um Arctic DV is basically it's a
python First Data frame database um
because of the origins in the world of
Finance where you know we have to deal
with things like like tick data from
exchanges built with uh intrinsic
support for kind of changing schema
missing data all that kind of stuff uh
right from the outset uh it supports M
multi-dimensional data and you've also
got all that kind of time travel and
versioning of
snapshots um I almost say it's a schema
database but that's not completely true
I mean each data frame has a schema um
and if you want to you can tell us all
of the schemas for all of the symbols
whenever they get modified rather than
you know overwritten so updated or
appended or whatever it has to be the
same if I add a column if I if I drop a
column that's a mistake uh on the other
hand if you don't care then um and you
want your schemas to evolve over time
you can for example you know create this
data frame with uh three columns you can
then create another one with four
columns and you an extra floating point
one you can append it to the first one
and then we don't go modify anything
about the the First Data frame but what
we do do at read time is we just figure
out where the columns are missing and we
back fill them with or whatever the kind
of type appropriate way to do that
is um so you know reading and writing a
nice it's it's nice to to have that but
I think the thing that we wanted to do
on before that is introduce some data
Transformations and we don't kind of
want to do the whole world of data
Transformations because you can get the
data out and you know you can use pandis
you can use P you can just polos
whatever you like uh you know to do
further work on it but there's a huge
advantage to being able to transforma
data as it's being read from Storage so
as each chunk comes out of storage you
know particularly in a case where it
might be super large it might not fit in
memory and also just for kind of
efficiency as the blocks are coming out
we're already transforming that already
getting them into this kind of like
really workable State um uh so we've got
this highly parallel vectorized
execution pipeline uh we actually
recently refactored it um it uses
something called an ECS architecture
which is borrowed from uh actually the
world of games programming stands for
entities components and systems so an
entity is kind of like a logical thing a
logical thing you want to refer to that
you're working on it has this changing
cast of kind of components underneath
which in our world are the you know the
kind of chunks of data and the slice
information that goes with them and all
the other stuff like you know groups if
we're doing some sort of partition um
and then systems are these stateless
kind of stes that just consume the
entities and their components and they
basically kind of write them to uh you
know um you know write them to a new
entity and pass it on to the next
stage um so we're going to go a little
bit bigger with the data now I'm going
to create um a data frame with 10
million rows um there's going to be one
row of random numbers between zero and
one just to crush any chance of good
compression um and then really high
cardinality string column with with um
100,000 strings um repeated not very
many times and then a low cardinality
string column with 10 strings repeated
loads and loads of
times and take a little while to
generate all those random strings there
we go and so at the end of it it just
looks like this we've got a numeric
column we've got our 100,000 strings
column we we got our our 10 uh string
column so in order to use this
processing we have this thing called the
query Builder and what the query Builder
is is basically it's like a lazy data
frame so you can do a lot of the
operations that would be familiar from
from pandis on it but rather than
reading everything in and then starting
to do operations it will apply those
operations in the correct sequence and
and as efficiently as we can with this
kind of C++ vectorized engine um you
know as as they come in
um uh so for example if I want to choose
all of the things um which are less than
0. five out of my uniform distribution
of numbers um I can do that in 66
milliseconds over the the 10 million
rows um and what it looks like as you
would imagine is um you know around
about half of those so so around about 5
million rows which is you know kind of
what you would expect given the the the
distribution um you can also create
columns on the Fly um just as you can
with with panda Supply um which database
people call projections but I've learned
since that nobody else does um so you
know we're just going to times that
numeric column by
two again 81
milliseconds and then here we go we
create this this new column called new
column and you know that's that's I
would say the thing with this is It's
You know the expression syntax will
handle expressions of arbitrary
complexity the really useful thing about
being able to do these applications is
not so much on their own although that's
kind of cool it's really um being able
to combine them with other things like
aggregations and filters so you can use
an expression to combine the results of
different columns um and then you can
aggregate or you can filter based on
that and it really allows you to kind of
Express a lot of quite complicated data
Transformations um a classic one is is
you know hashed uh hashed joins um group
buys whatever you like to call them um
so in 94 Mill seconds uh I can just join
um based on the the highly repeated
column um and get the averages of all of
those as you'd expect the mean tends
towards you know 0.5 because it's that
it's that um uh sort of uniform
distribution um you can do the same
thing in not very much more time over
the
100,000 um coming up to kind of half a
second to do that and interestingly you
know you see a little bit more um a
little bit more spread uh because you
know the law of large numbers is not
applying quite so much you've got fewer
things in each that are kind of
spreading a little bit either side of
the the 0.
five uh but like I said you know the
really really cool thing about it is the
fact that you can just chain all these
things together so you can create a new
column you can Group by it it uh you can
do you know multiple aggregations at the
same time um almost one of the
interesting things is one of the slow
things sometimes about python is you've
got to hold the gild to allocate strings
you know there's there's Sometimes some
copying inside python happens the more
you can do before you have to actually
pres present the results to python you
know the more the more sort of use you
can really get out of these um so there
you go that's that's um you know uh the
mean of the numeric one tending towards
0.5 again and the max of the other one
obviously tending toward WS two as we've
multiplied it uh what are we doing at
the moment um so Aros support is working
in a branch not quite ready for pi yet
uh resampling along the lines of pandis
resample and also sorting and merging so
you can really kind of just blast data
in in parallel you know really really
useful if you have kind of multiprocess
or you've got a big spark cluster or
something like that it can be all out of
order and overlapping but then if you
want to have it as one symbol will go in
and sort those things individually and
then merge them all together so you get
one kind of perfectly sorted time series
but you can really kind of spread the
workout um in future we want to do kind
of native spark support um joins which
are kind of actually technically similar
to um to aggregations uh a thing I think
is going to be really really useful is
called spil to storage and what that
means is that if you are um doing
computation and even the kind of
intermediate stage won't fit in memory
what we can do is we can take the ones
which are kind of partially done or
finished with we can write those back to
the storage as a kind of ephemeral chunk
and then free up some Ram to continue
doing the you know the thing we were
working on before and then at the end we
can either take that series and we can
write it back down to the storage if
it's too big to read or we can just if
the result set fits in memory then we
can return it to you we're probably
going to introduce a way to kind of read
stuff in chunks as well so if You' got a
a result that doesn't fit in memory you
can have you know a chunk and then ask
for the next chunk an exhaust an
iterator we're also going to work on um
being able to compact like I said with
databases um across symbol so if you
have a really really massive history of
versions actually uh combine them into
into really massive chunks to uh you
know to put those maybe in your glacia
storage or you know taper or whatever
you like um so that is it um if you
would like to know more then you can
find us at our website which is
.io actually has um uh uh notebooks
there you can go and actually play
around with it just write on the website
um interested in the code then then hit
us up on GitHub and then maybe give us a
start and if you want to try it in your
local environment then you know pip
install quandra install um whatever you
like uh thank you very
much thank you William um so we have a
bit of time left for some questions
there I think there was one put in the
chat but it sounds like you may have
answered it if you want to take a quick
look um are there any questions
questions from the audience this time
you can either put them in chat or in
the Q&A
section uh can you share what the system
specs are if you're running it locally I
am not entirely sure um I'm sorry I
think it's probably got about um I think
there's probably about 10 calls on it
and reasonable amount of ram but you
know actually I only went on this one
because normally we demo on uh an open
stack and K8 based kind of OnDemand
notebook and the performance is not that
much worse but it's like a Time slice
dual call thing with eight gig of RAM um
it's a bit sad because obviously one of
the advantages of C++ we get lots of
parallelism um and uh you know so then
we're doing it with two ques where
there's almost no parallelism at all and
the eight gig makes me super nervous for
this sort of thing just I couldn't
generate it is amaz thing I could
probably read it but I couldn't do the
gener
um so I think it's probably got about 64
gigs of RAM but I'm I'm genuinely not
sure I just borrowed this machine for
the talk like I can let you know